Ось дивіться, які легені. Права є. Лівої геть немає.
Харків б’є усі антирекорди України за кількістю хворих на COVID-19.
За день у лікарні міста та області надходять 600-700 нових пацієнтів,
тоді як у травні 1000 випадків фіксували в цілому за місяць.
Стрімко зростає і летальність.  Здорова людина, застерігають лікарі, може померти за 3-5 днів.
Значною мірою перебіг хвороби залежить і від того, куди саме прибувають хворі.
Зокрема, самі харків'яни у соцмережах негативно відгукуються про ті лікарні,
які змушені були перепрофілюватися внаслідок пандемії.
Харків’янка Анастасія поховала дідуся, якого привезла до 25-ої міської лікарні наприкінці вересня.
Як стверджує Анастасія, дідусеві не одразу дали кисень, не було і ліків.
Водночас спочатку лікарі нібито запевняли родичів, що мають усе необхідне. Коли ж таки визнали, що медикаментів бракує
та отримали їх від родичів, препарат ввели не одразу, а через добу. Дідусь Анастасії вже був у вкрай важкому стані.
Людина похилого віку, 81 рік. Він був спортсменом, в нього було абсолютно нормальне здоров’я.
Він міг це перенести, якби йому була надана своєчасна допомога. Але допомоги ніякої не було.
Я кожного разу йому телефонувала, кажу, мовляв, до тебе хтось підходив? Ніхто не підходив!
Потім виявилось, що в них в принципі на весь поверх була одна медсестра.
5 діб дідусь пролежав, по суті, без жодної меддопомоги!
Тепер Анастасія шкодує, що не була обізнана про реальну ситуацію в лікарні, де не було ані ліків,
ані дихальних апаратів та бракувало навіть лікарів.
У них там, якщо не помиляюсь, 70-80 хворих. І три лікарі. Як їм бути? Вони намагаються, туди-сюди розриваються.
Але знову ж таки, я, якщо чесно, не впевнена, що там працюють профільні лікарі, приміром, пульманологи.
На жаль, я не розуміла цього. Якби я це знала тоді, то дідуся ні за що не відвезла б.
Ми би краще вдома залишились, я би купила йому кисневий балон.
DW марно намагалася з'ясувати у головного лікаря, чому пацієнти з коронавірусом можуть,
як дідусь Анастасії, лежати 5 днів у лікарні, не отримуючи допомогу.
На всі телефонні запити у секретаріаті відповідали відмовами через постійну зайнятість головлікаря.
Не пояснив він і причини, з яких наприкінці вересня з його лікарні хотіли звільнитися 10 лікарів і медсестр.
Не на камеру медпрацівники розповіли DW, що просто відмовлялися працювати без засобів захисту,
ліків, дихальних апаратів і за зарплатню, яку тільки обіцяють підвищити.
За даними мерії, цей конфлікт був розв’язаний, і більшість лікарів повернулися до роботи.
Мерія також неодноразово запевняла, що проблеми із захистом лікарів,
забезпеченістю препаратами та апаратурою поступово вирішуються.
Утім, волонтерка Наталя Попова, яка розвозить по лікарнях гуманітарну допомогу, категорично спростовує це твердження.
Місто ігнорувало проблему COVID усе літо. Все літо! І зараз, коли запустилися міські лікарні, окрім 17-ої, вони не готові.
Лікарі не забезпечені засобами захисту! Дзвонять лікарі і просять привезти венфлон-катетери.
Немає! Просять привезти респіратори! Тому що можуть на зміну в ковідне відділення вийти в масці!
Волонтерка розповідає, що випадки, коли лікарі звільняються чи погрожують звільнитися, непоодинокі.
При відкритті лікарень в області і в місті з лікарями не була проведена та робота, при якій вони б залишилися.
Наприклад, відкриваючи опорне відділення в диспансері радіаційного захисту,
ми перестраховувалися, перевозили перших пацієнтів  з інфекційної лікарні і садили в швидку лікарів з інфекційної,
вони разом з пацієнтами їхали.
І коли ми довезли, частина лікарів чорнобильської лікарні просто пішли додому зі зміни і сказали, що ми звільняємося.
Коли відкрилася міська опорна лікарня, сталося те ж саме, лікарі покинули робочі місця, але ніхто їх не перестраховував.
Те, що пацієнти тоді залишилися живі, - це диво.
До жовтня Харків, каже волонтерка, насправді рятували профільні інфекційні лікарні обласного підпорядкування,
які відповідно до медичної реформи, мають приймати людей за пропискою.
В обласній інфекційній лікарні наразі 80% хворих на COVID-19  – мешканці Харкова, решта – з області.
Ось як нині виглядає черга зі швидких. У машинах - пацієнти, стан яких наближається до вкрай важкого.
Ось все! Тепер можна у вогнище! У вогнище інфекції.
Головний лікар обласної інфекційної лікарні Харкова називає свій заклад "суцільною реанімацією".
Адже усі 240 ліжок заповнені. Лікарі відверто кажуть, що не усі ці хворі повернуться додому
і заявляють про відсутність ліків, які є в національному переліку лікування COVID-19.
Адже їхні закупівлі на рівні держави відбулися із запізненням або взагалі не відбулися.
Приміром, обіцяний урядом у вересні і ще не закуплений державою противірусний препарат ремдесивір
5-денний курс якого коштує від двох з половиною тисяч доларів.
Такі кошти мають не усі хворі. Ресурсів благодійників теж на усіх не вистачає.
Одна з головних проблем - оці  препарати прямої противірусної дії. Знайти їх. Ми лікуємо цими препаратами.
Люди привозять з-за кордону: з ФРН, зі США привозять ці препарати через свої зв’язки. І ми призначаємо.
Не вистачає лікарні і приміщень для інтенсивної терапії, і персоналу.
В цю маленьку кімнату - на 12 ліжок - постійно утворюється черга з хворих.
Якщо брати нашу лікарню, то за світовим досвідом на ту кількість ліжок, яка є,  необхідно 40 ліжок інтенсивної терапії
і відповідна кількість персоналу. У нас працює 12 ліжок, не вистачає 28-ми
і, відповідно, персоналу. Треба збільшити втричі.
Лікарі б’ють на сполох, адже в реанімації потрібні лікарі й інших спеціалізацій.
Загострення цукрового діабету, інфаркти, інсульти, ниркова недостатність. Один анестезіолог не зможе з цим впоратися.
Проте ці лікарі прийти сюди не можуть, бо оплата цих послуг за ковідним пакетом не передбачена.
Харківська лікарня закликає уряд і НСЗУ терміново ухвалити якесь рішення щодо можливості збільшити штатний розклад.
Якщо чесно, ситуація вкрай напружена.  Якщо аналізувати, то з квітня вона погіршилася в 10 разів.
І хворі, які зараз госпіталізуються, їм необхіднанині більш кваліфікована допомога.
Якщо, наприклад, хворих на етапі госпіталізації сортувати - невропатологія - визначити такий заклад,
кардіологія, тоді, напевно, буде менше проблем.
Ще одна проблема майже кожної лікарні Харкова - дефіцит кисневих концентраторів.
Тепер вони потрібні в майже кожній палаті, а не лише реанімаційній, як це передбачалося досі.
І не один апарат на кілька хворих, а окремий - кожному.
На початкових етапах розвитку дихальної недостатності він допомагає. Катастрофічно не вистачає.
50- 80. Саме 10-ти-15-ти літрових концентраторів.
Міська і обласна влада на тлі антирекордної статистики пообіцяла закупити додаткові кисневі концентратори.
Кисень - це постійний головний біль усіх лікарень Харківщини. В обласній інфекційній до епідемії
на рік купували кисню на 100 000 гривень. Зараз витрачають вже 700 000 на місяць.
Це дуже багато. У нас раніше місяць тому ми заправляли раз на три дні, а зараз кожен день приїжджає машина і заправляє.
Уряд зобов’язав місцеву владу забезпечити 80% ліжок киснем, виділивши регіонам 572 мільйони гривень.
Однак на практиці, кажуть харківські лікарі, через бюрократичні процедури провести кисневі точки за один день
чи навіть тиждень та запустити туди заздалегідь закуплений кисень неможливо.
Наш народ щось, звичайно, вигадає, підуть в хід саморобні прилади - мішки на голову замість сіпапів.
Люди будуть підлаштовуватися. Якою ціною? Покаже час!
Чи буде це Бергамо або Барселона? Або це буде Нью-Йорк!? ... Але це буде важко!
Ще важче буде, каже волонтерка, якщо проблема з відсутністю нових анестезіологів на тлі зростання захворюваності
серед працюючих лікарів не буде вирішена. Лікарні, де побувала DW, вже пережили
хвилю захворюваності серед співробітників.
Дехто звільнився. Замість них ще ніхто не прийшов. У лікарнях констатують дефіцит кадрів.
У нас відділення на 120 пацієнтів. Нам вже треба  10 лікарів і 20 медсестр і стільки ж санітарок.
Але немає кадрів, які хотіли б працювати з "ковідом". Просто бояться люди інфекції. Просто острах.
Подібні проблеми виникають і в інших регіонах. В Офісі президента пропонують, зокрема, залучати студентів медінститутів.
Крім того, якщо коронавірусна статистика зростатиме такими ж темпами, не виключено, що будуть розгортати госпіталі
за межами лікарень - на стадіонах, в будинках культури тощо.
За даними Харківської облдерж адімінстрації, найближчим часом у місті та області планують відкрити 320 додаткових ліжок.
Водночас лише зараз місцева влада почала реальну інформаційну компанію
серед населення із закликом дотримуватися протиепідемічних правил.
Адже, попри сумну статистику, досі харків’яни демонстрували здебільшого отаку небезпечну недбалість…